聽說你從做全鎮十萬
到一千萬只花七個月
四百萬全雜
隔天八百
一天就變成八百
我現在很後悔一件事
我09年認識的是古瑜
全鎮絕對不能擺太久
擺越久它是越墊越低
對 容易越來越低
有人說那花全美四十四
不要看了
沒差 不需要長相私手
六天就賺五倍啦
對
最怕的東西來了
登登
南東
那三
鬼林古
最怕的就是鬼靈高
再跟你講一下
暗黑面
好 怎麼那麼多暗黑面
發行商只要好
損益一定爛
佛心
對投資人佛心
投資人就很容易賺錢
不賺錢的發行商是好的
今天是我做理財達人秀以來
最緊張的一集
很恐怖啊
很恐怖很恐怖
來準備一堆問題尻
因為今天是你主場啊
對
對啊 因為你是全政小哥
我們今天竟然要講全政
偏偏我又很少做全政
我是追求低風險
所以我現在覺得壓力很大
全政很多問題啊
你不要考一些我不會的
專門考不會的
怎麼說
讓人家知道我們節目沒有在Re的
你可不可以先TEST一題
好 TEST一題
我先問你
全政的名字
居然說
友達
群義
九九
購01
友達是他連結的標的
權益是發行商
99-01
99什麼意思
愛你99
購01你是我的唯一
太難了
再聊下去不能來上節目
99-01
第一個9是109年
109年9月到期
所以就是99
99-01就是9月到期
那夠是更夠全政
那假如前面名字都一樣的話
01就是第一檔
這樣講就懂了
就懂了就懂了
好啦 我有信心
隨堂考
隨堂考 等一下會一直隨堂考就對了
好 今天我趙華在這邊要求大家
各位廣大網友給我一個支持好不好
因為小哥 全政小哥
這一集的歌有仇必報
他就要來講全政囉
全政的話有點算是趙華的趙門
但是小哥很有信心
小哥說講完這一集
趙華也會做全政
但是今天有很多的隨堂考
考我 然後也考網友
所以網友如果知道答案的話
好不好 給我一個pass
不然的話
我真的會被小哥問到牙口無言
但是我們今天還是要先問小哥
小哥 你那麼會賺錢
你幹嘛不叫投資小哥
不叫股票小哥
要叫全政小哥
因為我是從全政翻身的
翻身
我在2008年的時候
2008年10月
我就是錢大概輸了100多萬
100多萬
當時好像已經是你的積蓄的大部分了
對不對
大部分
因為我還有把一些積蓄拿去蓋房子
我們家房子是自建的
拿去蓋房子
最後剩下10萬塊
10萬塊
他講說10萬塊要幹嘛
他拿來存股嘛
對啊
拿來存股一年大概賺個8000
我們前幾集有別的單元
才在講定期定額存股
10萬塊感覺8000好像
要把我的100多萬 pay回來
好像有點困難 對
那時候剛好2009年1月開始
全證的造勢新制開始
有一個造勢新制 對
跟各位講
只要造勢新制開始的時候
越新的東西就越有漏洞
因為那時候全證槓桿都很高
因為剛開始
自行商都賣得很便宜
那一天
把那些全震 漲停板的全震
而且漲停板是合理報價全震
現在沒有了
現在漲停板都是不合理的
漲停板合理報價全震把它收刮完
收刮一空用400萬嗎
400萬買完 為什麼那麼大膽呢
因為隔天還會大漲
因為摩台15%隔天又一根
400萬全雜
小哥你的個性也是
隔天800
隔天就800 一天就變成800
一天就800
因為買完之後隔天又一根漲停
股票又漲停
那槓桿你想想看
槓桿你挑比較高的
你挑個10倍好了
7乘以10
因為10倍槓桿
漲停滿它還不只70%
有可能隔天就翻倍了
所以你就變成800萬身價
而且聽說你從做全鎮10萬
到1000萬只花7個月
我現在很後悔一件事
就是我2009年認識的是谷宇
對
那個時候
那個時候有人說
你知道嗎
當天買什麼最好買基金
基金爆價它有時候跟當天的爆價
會有點落差 它近期會有點落差
買基金不錯啦
也是有多按7%
但是當時用全證最好
但是這個漏洞已經沒有了
沒有了 這bug沒有
那現在怎麼辦
你竟然來上理財丹秀
所以我們現在10萬變千萬的速度
不會那麼快
不會那麼快 慢慢來
可是你今天有帶例子來
就是幾倍的還是很多
沒錯 好 我們來看
第一檔
真的 這個我最喜歡了
用1000塊錢就可以了
對 全鎮特色就是他錢不用太多
用一點點錢就可以
對
這檔是滑傾
我們來看一下滑傾
滑傾各位看一下
股災它沒什麼影響
對啊 為什麼
為什麼 好強
各位還記得我們的第三集嗎
布林通道
標股的條件
對 還記得嗎
記得
第一個 主力要幹嘛
要買 主力買
對 上軌
而且不靈通道要先說窄
然後沿著上軌突破
對 就去搶第一根
主力買上軌翹 對
老公開心 老婆也開心
你看一下 這個
你講買先給的話
小哥我們是財經節目
我講的是財經啊
老公賺錢給老婆花
老婆就要開心 超開心的
這是財經節目
好 那你各位看一下
這個花錢從80幾塊漲到100多塊
這是現股的部分
當時你假如買一檔權證
這兩個是049985
049985這檔權證
就從1塊錢最高漲到5塊
5塊
對 短短幾天啊
6天賺5倍
5倍
而且這是1000 如果放1萬
放1萬
我放10萬
10萬變50萬
我放100萬
我就比小哥當年一夜翻一倍還要多
對 這個就很快
這要花六天
好 這要花六天
六天是五倍啊
小哥你那個事後論
事後早數上股票給我看
對 我跟你講好多人很喜歡這樣講
看圖說故事誰不會
對 我們來看一下
這是我設計的
2020年1月15號
對
上軌斜率 上通斜率
它1.2%
上市說1%就可以了
1%就是強制率
然後主力這邊都買超
所以主力這邊數字很多
這邊還有一個主力連買
它主力已經連買7天了
那個時候花錢才80幾塊而已
連買7天會不會不買了
就是我們什麼時候退場
離開上通道再退場
來給各位看一天
一天五倍
但這一天五倍
這個要憑什麼
這是憑人品的
這個看運氣的
我人品一定不好
因為我LINE你沒有通知我
這個要看運氣的
而且還要看市場上的呆子多不多
怎麼說呢
因為這個價格是呆子買的
這價格呆子買
我們不能買這個就對了
隔天這一塊錢不能買
所以你假如買到190塊買
代表你用0.19買
這價格才0.19而已
0.19買隔天你可以賣一塊
等於說呆子買在這裡
你賣在這裡
對 你賣給呆子
那我們這個節目做完之後
對 呆子又變少了
很可惜啊
我不大想做這節目
但是小哥要教我
怎麼樣能買在這裡啊
買在這邊
你說買在這邊
然後賭他一根大跌嗎
這個呢 沒辦法
沒有辦法 我只是舉例而已
你叫我找出連貿這天會跌停
沒有辦法
對 一點徵兆都沒有
只是純舉例
好 這就是人品爆發
對 人品爆發
但是其實 剛好有人買
小哥會預測
我們其實在前幾集
每一次都逼小哥預測
像均線扣底值那一集
也要你預測他的走勢
所以其實這個除了拚人品之外
有的是可以預測的
對 有的可以預測
我們現在看一個故事
好 最近的故事
最近的 第一集各位記得嗎
光頭大紅棒收購一定要搶
對 收購跳空一致線
對
這個剛好又來了
友達公開收購林華科技
我們有學到耶
所以我們看到消息
就立刻問小哥隔天是不是
登登登登登登登
去敲掌面
我就跟他講隔天搶
對
因為這個
沒有人講到
不過搶了你還是要看一下
這個節目要看仔細一點
我們有講說
你搶之前看一下
微買有幾張
對
我記得當天微買有到
六七十萬張
是
所以六七十萬張你就可以搶
好
這個第一集都有交
大家廣告一看第一集
收購這個小哥是
有交一些條件下非搶不可
對
你一定要看微買張數喔
好 那天我看了
委买張數六七十萬之後
我就去按了
我把我所有戶頭都按完了
然後
委託買進
委託買進成功
一直按 全部戶頭按完
那有沒有成交成功啊
沒成交成功
我好安慰
所以我就不太想來這節目了
因為這節目錄完之後
那一集啊
這邊要改一下
一變13萬了
多了13萬個交易敵人
不止你那一集的点月破10万
所以多了22万个交易的敌人
为什么
破10万一个点月
一个点月还告诉他亲朋好友
天哪
难怪我那时候就买不到
所以很多招式一交
那个交易难度会变高
所以我们来做节目是做功德的
做功德来看一下
这是小哥赖我们吗
这个是我的Light
Light 5万多人定
所以大家都有目共睹
5万多人
所以你去看
這沒辦法作假
所以小哥你對我們沒有特別
就是群發的五萬分之一
群發五萬多人都看到
小哥卻預言全震將大跌你看你上次叫我預言股票大跌我覺得好困啊 股票大跌但預言全震大跌很簡單我在這邊寫了
明天臨華的全震要大跌了
隔天臨華還漲7%
對 還漲7%
不懂全震可別亂買
因為我知道小哥你現在
第一你知道臨華隔天的走勢
第二你已經看到這些全震
隔天會跟臨華走勢脫鉤的問題
脫鉤 因為隔天這些全證一定會跌
為什麼 因為前天被買太高了
對 比如說他已經離開他原本應該有的價值了
太瘋狂了 我巴不得全證可以放空
全證只要可以放空 我一定去空凌華的全證
但是現在全證不能放空 各位看一下
果然隔天 第一個
這場凌華永豐9401 這是股票走勢
林華股票大漲
漲得7%
林華的全震開盤平盤
平盤各位看 開盤1.23
這個人為什麼去買呢
林華漲我全震還沒漲就去買
就直接買
他就是沒有訂閱我的Lite
有訂閱他就知道說
林華全震今天會大跌
不要亂買
今天會大跌你還買
一買你看他開盤買1.23
收盤剩0.58
這是比腰斬還腰斬
很慘
你看這當天真的是跌超過50%
跌超過52%
買一張1230塊
收盤剩580塊
那很慘喔
這就是投資人他不曉得
權證的合理價格應該怎麼算
那到底
臨華的權證出什麼問題
還有這邊加位小哥一提
趁小哥考我
當天都沒有臨華的權證可以買了嗎
你說在漲停板的時候嗎
對
你必須要先計算它的合理價
所以看來小哥法眼一看
都已經不行了
都不行了
看它漲不就這樣不行了
各位看一下
當天的全震走勢
那我們為什麼要特別
用這張圖給各位看
要給各位看一個東西
林華在盤整的時候
各位看一下
全震事實上怎麼樣
它在緩步下跌
林華漲它有漲
只是越來越低
越来越低
所以全震特别特别
要告诉观众
全震绝对不能摆太久
第一个是全震不能摆太久
全震不能摆太久
因为它会越来越低
那它跟股价波动高低
有没有关系
它涨它都有涨
但是它摆越久
它是越电越低
容易越来越低
所以我们只是希望怎么样
我们只是去找那种
它明天可能会涨
我就进场
然后一两两三天之后我就出场
要賺那個就好
好 那林華大賞全震你看
這開盤跳空開高這麼高
也太高了
這個一開盤就是一個不合理價錢了
隔天它就立馬大家也可以下來
所以這現股大賞7%
全震就跌52%
所以小哥這邊要告訴我們全震的原理
對 因為我們今天這堂課很佛心的就是說
我相信很多人
因為我們之前其實陸陸續續
小哥的競爭對手阿哥
也講過全震
可是還滿多人留言說
我聽完我還是沒有很懂
所以小哥你今天有個任務
就是我聽完
我會想買全證
而且我會賺錢
好 把你交到懂
把我交到懂
而且我要去下單喔
好 沒問題
我們先從最基本的開始交
全證
這是全證的身份證
有達群益99-01
這我剛剛有回答過了
我剛剛破題有講
對 愛你99嘛 你是唯一
我現在再問你
又有問題
好
你這是全鎮的新制
以前沒有那麼長
以前全鎮名字只有四個
四個嘛
例如說這檔
它可能就叫群役AA
AA就像車牌號碼一樣
就是AA制
各副各的
車牌號碼一樣輪流
輪流AAB
AAB A C A D
很簡單
對 它這樣發
可是發到一段時間
發行商覺得怪怪的
我怎麼發這行全證
怎麼特別好賣
你知道發到哪個嗎
為什麼 哪個
發到群益LV
LV
投資人 哇
LV也不管標的
因為上面標的你也看不到
群益LV就進去買了
所以你說嘛
市場呆子是不是很多
呆子很多
群益有在賣LV
那麼便宜0.5塊
進去買
小哥你是看完下來認真
我認真
認真
另外一檔就發現滯銷
你知道哪一檔嗎
滴滴
沒有 群翼LP
那時候有這種笑話嗎
真的 我跟你講真的
我認真上節目
群翼是不錯的券商
就是買群翼的LP也不會怎麼樣
是這樣子嗎
可是你拿起你的褲筍
看LP 感覺都怪怪的
而且時間價值可能不長
還有一種更難賣
叫什麼嗎
還有啊
群義GG
你看褲子
哇 GG
帶曬帶曬 不要買
這些呢
因為這樣子
乾脆改名好了啦
不然每次LP都賣光
LP都自銷
GG更差
GG跳過 不要發GG
所以這個以後就改名成這樣
這樣子改名
第一個名字變很長
看起來一目了然
對 資訊都在裡面
對 友達標的 群役99的券商
1099的券商 很清楚
第二個 他有分兩種權證
認購跟認售
看多跟看空
看多 認購 看空 認售
第二個 履約方式有分美式跟什麼
美式跟歐式
你怎麼不講美式跟拉鐵呢
答對了 美式跟歐式
可是我不知道什麼不一樣
美式跟歐式 真的好
美式跟歐式差在哪
差在一個是美國人 一個是法國人
法國人就浪漫 美國人就現實
美國人現實 我要跟你分手
美國人 我要跟你分手
來 結算給我 結算給我
美國人要跟你分手 結算給我
美國人會說怎麼樣
就是要算清楚算帳
立馬來 立馬結算
今天離婚 明天分財產
所以這些權政的你買了之後
我要跟你分手
我不要在市場上賣了
我直接跟你親的結算
可以啊 每天可結算
每天可結算
叫美式
那歐式呢
你要跟我分手等等啊
我們到期日好不好
我們到期日
2020年9月3號再來結算
好 來來來
我們現在講比較難的
來 旅約一下10塊
10塊的意思就是說
你在哪一天啊
你在到期日那一天
對
9月3號
你可以去跟群毅說
賣我10塊友達
懂我意思嗎
懂
10塊賣我
好
假如當時友達漲到100塊
我問你 這張值多少錢
這張就賺90塊啊
對 聰明
對 賺翻了
這張就賺90塊
各位看一下
它現在大概值2塊
對
假如你認為友達
在9月多會漲到100塊的話
對
那你現在買歐
至少20塊
哇 到90
到90
我說全震的價格
有達到100它就到90
是這樣子跟的
對它跟
它只有減這個10塊而已
對100減10塊再乘以形式比例1
我怕太難
我挑一個形式比例1再來
謝謝小哥
因為事業上全震
那個形式比例有0.003
那個很難算
就刻意讓你算不出來
挑個1的簡單
有達100塊它值90
80塊值70
等於現價去減這個10乘以1
對那個價格
那個價值叫做內含價值
內含價值
好 那我们来看一下友达
友达最近很强
但偷偷告诉各位
友达现在建议你
不要再去追了
因为关键分点
因为友达买临华之后
还有一个消息是说
友达可能之后
还有很多这种收购案
那你买不到临华人就觉得
那我去买友达好了
因为我们都看分点了
关键分点在这个地方是大卖的
总之歌有仇必报
所以筹码告訴你
筹码告訴我
所以友達這邊我不太追
所以我們只是講友達例子
不要去追他
好
那這個友達這檔全證
股票11塊的時候
全證已經到2塊了
那這檔全證是不是
有一點點超過了
超過了
超過的叫做時間價值
時間價值
你看這檔全證很好玩
因為還到9月才要履約
對
它從0.8就漲到2塊
它也漲了多少
漲了2倍多了
漲了2倍多
各位看到
有大概是從8塊漲到11塊
這樣才大概兩三成而已
對 買股票兩三成
買全震兩三倍
這是全震有趣的地方
好 全震有趣的地方
好 那這個上市2019年12月4號
最後交易日
這檔全震是9個月
通常發行是6個月
所以這檔還比較長
對 有6個月 9個月 12個月都有
好 那現在因為它漲很多
所以它是一個價內的權證
剛剛有講說超過履約價值
就是價內
價內權證
好 我們再來看下一個
好 好 接下來
聽得懂了
我們花了非常多力氣
解釋這張身份證
然後但是身份證
還有四個密碼
好 我們來看四個密碼
這身份證呢
第一個到期日很重要
這個一定都看得到
對 其實你看名字就知道了
就知道了
109年4月到期
哇 聰明
照我一交二會
來 第二個
這個價內外程度它什麼
價外
15%價外
對
價外代表說你現在拿去履約
沒有履約價值
沒有履約價值要價外
實質槓桿6.5倍
6.5倍的高低
6.5倍什麼意思
6.5倍算不錯了
還不錯
大概5倍以上槓桿就算高
槓桿5倍以上
對
那6.5倍什麼意思
就是它股票漲1%
對
這檔全震的微買
各位
我們在講微買
微買就會漲6%
是這個意思
微買會漲6%
微買漲6%
因為這個微買是發行商控制的他們電腦自己忙碎所以這是他自己設定的條件縣股漲1%他就要微滿要變成6%
這個數值每天會變動
因為他會跟到期有關
會每天變動
所以小哥等一下要教我們怎麼去查變動
之後還有價差比
待會再教
價差比也很重要
大家先把名詞記下來
價差比等一下會教
這個價內價外
有人看到這個想睡價外
我跟你講小哥
全正在我一開始跑股票
我就知道了
可是我到現在看到
價內價外還是一樣
想睡
這個教你
只要你去旅約的時候
有拿到錢叫價內
因為我是內行人
內行人
所以我有拿到錢
對
拿不到錢叫價外
我外行人
這樣夠簡單嗎
夠簡單
旅約拿到錢價內
價內就自己人
自己人給錢
對 價外就外面的
外面的自己去外面買口罩
不給你
對
有口罩嗎
有有有
好 來
那價內呢
認購全證就股價大於旅月價
因為可以旅月了嘛
對
認售就小於
好
那價平就兩個相等
相等
那價外就
認購全證就股價小於旅月價
對
比旅月價高嘛
股價比較低
旅月價比較高
就價外
好 來
這個這張圖
每次看到這張圖一堆都睡著了
小哥如果這張圖啊
你能講到所有的網友懂啊
好不好通告費漲十倍
真的
你說的喔
那待會留言要調查
來來來
你等一下怎麼考我都不會答對了
問你一個問題啦 很簡單啦
旅月價格10塊
我今天買全證我花了全力金花一塊
然後我就抱著
等到他履約
等他履約 我問你
股價要多少你才會打平
11塊
你會了 通告費漲長
等一下
11塊
等一下 這是剛剛上一張身份證交的
對 你懂了
通告費 先漲1萬
等一下 口罩多準備幾個
現在都是口罩抵通告費
那是股瑜的股
不是
後面股價大漲
例如說股價到100塊
你有可能就會賺很多
所以認購權政有個特色
它會越賺越多
股價越漲賺越多
好 那認購
好 接下來講認售
認售就看空
對 來 看空
我們一樣 履業價還是花10塊
然後權利價還是1塊
來 你認為要跌到多少錢
你有沒有看空
這個履業價10塊
9塊 太厲害了
這個就是9塊
這是9塊
但是認售有個缺點
因為只不過跌到0
對 沒錯
所以這場全震
它的天花板價格又多少
0塊 就是下市
天花板就沒有
這是認售的
天花板價格就是
股價已經跌到0.01
這場全震天花板價格就9塊
天花板價格就9塊
點多9塊 因為雖然0.01
對 就是認售全震
所以這張圖就這樣
等於是買認購就上漲無限
可是下跌是有限的
全證受是有限的
好 接下來
全證呢
我上一張沒睡這張可以睡一下
有啦來
那價內跟價外呢
到底要挑哪個好
對 這也是我的疑問
你說價內可以拿到錢
所以我要設法買到我變成價內
對 對 很好
價內跟價外各有優缺點
怎麼說 價外不就聽起來
就是好像沒什麼好處
價外呢 這樣講
價外的全證利率比較高
全證有點像你跟發行商借錢買股票
對
他借錢買股票之後
他又算你利息不好算
他就直接在報價那邊顯示出來
對
所以你買價內全證
你發現擺一段時間利率比較低
那價外擺一段時間利率很高
對
所以
我借錢買股票利率高不是壓力很大嗎
對 壓力比較大
對
所以很多人
很多人寫書都會跟你講
你要買價外權證
你知道為什麼嗎
可是利率高 我壓力大
剛剛如果小哥一解釋
我要講一點暗黑面好了
好 真的嗎
出書的暗黑面嗎
好 這樣子
坊間的一堆書都是抄的
抄來抄去來 我抄你 你抄我
那總有個源頭
源頭是誰你知道嗎 誰
發行商
因為發行商要教你玩
賭場要教你遊戲規則
所以一直叫你買價外的
其實發行商一開始在
他叫你買價外權證
對他而言有利
我懂了
所以发行商都不想发小哥做那个业配
对 就像有些东西
他会叫你买全新的
不要买二手的
但其实二手CP值还是好的
对 没错
那输超一超
很多人叫你买价外
其实价外也有它的好处
但是呢
通常你买价内优点比较多
小哥已经帮我们二分之一筛选了
就是买价内优点比较多
优点比较多
对 如果输学者就是
我觉得进阶的话
去聊有价外
有些時間點
我們在下一集會講
會講
那價內通常槓桿比較小
價外的好處就是槓桿大
我懂了
有點賭一把的意味
賭一把
所以明天要法說會拼了
就找價外
對
賭他明天大漲
或是明天大跌
就跟他拼了
我懂了
所以覺得有賭一把的機會
賭一把買價外
然後偷偷告訴你
資料股票會漲喔
什麼時候會漲不知道
那就很難賭了
三個月後可能會出來
我全證都到期了
我全都到期了
今天雙煤漲停板
結果買雙煤全證的一堆到期
好可憐
有個主力大買雙煤
很可憐 賠很多
那就是因為要到期了
你假如賭一天的
價外還不錯
價內風險低 價外風險高
因為它容易歸零
價內報酬低
因為它槓桿比較小
所以報酬比較低
價外報酬比較高
那價內可以履約
旅約有錢啦
有錢拿嘛
價外旅約沒有錢啦
所以買價外的話
如果你報到旅約
通常就大賠了對不對
對 好
小哥教你挑好權證
重點來了嘛
重點來了
直接告訴我們怎麼挑
我跟你講你去外面看書
書這樣叫你挑權證
跟挑老婆一樣
對 不可能
條件列一大堆
對
那我們這個把它精簡再精簡
對 只有我這樣子是完美
但是也沒有辦法
一看OK
像小哥也完美
可是小哥就引金
對不對
在別人家了
在別人家
好 挑權證呢
三大條件 第一個 差槓比低
三個字聽不懂 沒關係 待會講
容易賺錢 先記住 差槓比要低
第二個 偏價內
偏價內就是這樣權政
它的會比較優秀一點
剛剛有講過 其實它的風險比較低
第三個 要挑好的發行商
什麼是好發行商
好的發行商
那麼多發行商
這個證交所
它有一個權政的
資訊揭露平台
介護平台
你可以上網去看
看發行商最近好不好
怎麼樣最近好不好
因為是這樣子
這個再跟你講一下暗黑面
好 怎麼那麼多暗黑面
我在吃藏太久了
發行商只要好
他的損益一定爛
不賺錢
因為他很有良心
佛心
他很佛心
對投資人很佛心
投資人就很容易賺錢
他就賺很少
好 不賺錢的發行商是好的
所以現在有點麻煩
就是發言商太好
他可能賺不到錢
賺不到錢
他可能頭頭會被換掉
他可能又變壞發言商
所以發言商好壞會一直在那邊猶疑
所以發言商好壞
就會去看網站
但是你這邊有講
避免降隱含波動率
就是我好的發言商
不會隨便去給你降隱含波動率
待會會給你看一張讀
我懂你的意思了
那買全鎮最怕的東西來了
登登
南東 山 龜鈴膏
這個意思
最怕的就是龜鈴膏
你知道龜鈴膏是昏的還是素的
龜 龜 龜 昏的
對 不是仙草棟喔
不是仙草棟喔
它是昏的
好 那為什麼龜鈴膏很恐怖喔
你聽到他做全鎮
不要送他龜鈴膏
會翻臉的你知道嗎
所以做全鎮赤婚的對不對
送他玉米
好 送他玉米
還貝啊
就素的
還貝的翻貝的意思
祝你全鎮翻貝又翻貝
送他玉米
不要送他龜苓膏
好
那很多人買全鎮
前幾天都有人傳他的損益給我
對
小哥 我的全鎮完蛋了嗎
我一看 負90%
真的完蛋了
我就跟他講說
你還是要挑一天把它賣掉
因為全證擺太久了
我說擺太久很不利
講了老半天沒有人信
我就請製作人
禮拜天晚上跟他聊兩個小時
請他幫我做這個
非常好
不會給他加班費
為了做30分鐘節目
聊兩個小時
我就跟他講
這個全證
我們禮拜天找資料
2萬多檔
那其中限價比發行價
低五成以上
就2萬多檔有9700檔已經腰斷了
就是賠一半了
對 47%腰斷了
47%賠一半啊
對 然後再放到期日只剩三個月
到期日小於三個月的
小於三個月的
還有11000多檔
這個只剩有60%腰斷了
到期日只剩一個月有69%腰斷了
你看多恐怖啊
多恐怖小哥你還教我們這個
我就是要幫助各位
不然我沒教你
你買了之後把它當獻股用
所以你這邊也告訴我們
到期日越長的
事實上它腰斬的比率
事實上是比較低的
時間價值的問題
這邊的重點是說
你買全日就不要擺太久
不要擺太久
因為有的人說
小哥那我挑比較長的嗎
我說不用啊
也不是
長有長的好 短有短的好
我們是財經節目
短的槓桿大
長的時間價值流失慢所以長的比較稍微能放短的你就要剝一把了對 短的剝一把那到底說要買幾天到幾天看你要幹嘛你說我今天買了
我明天就要出了
那到期日無所謂
不行 你不能買到今天到期
一個月還行這樣
一個月就可以
有的人說你不要買到一個月
我說沒關係
你要跟他拼了
一個月也可以
所以不一定
好 所以這全證關鍵是這樣
時間要抓緊
不要跟他長相私手
那全陣挑到底要怎麼挑呢
我現在考你
又要考我
來...你的男朋友
男朋友要送你300萬的禮物
讓你挑一個
兩克拉兩公斤
都是等價300萬就對了
300萬查過了
小哥演一下我男朋友可以嗎
不要撩
這個純白無瑕
純潔無瑕的兩克拉300萬
這個兩公斤也300萬
我算過了差不多
男朋友300萬現金
太慫太慫
同臭味
不行 兩個跳一個
我跟你講
大家都會以為出這個女生喜歡鑽石
告訴你我絕對不會選鑽石
因為我剛剛好幫朋友
賣過三克拉的鑽石
超難賣
你好聰明喔
黃金
黃金價差不大
對 我跟各位講一下
我有去查過
鑽石呢
你假如跟有良心的買
回收價說我今天帶不大好看
幫我回收一下
300萬隔天回收價有證書的
對 什麼GIA證書
GIA證書 有證書 沒證書就慘了
記得拿證書
有證書的300萬隔天回收
可能只剩210
這是有良心的
有良心的
我問到的更點點點
很恐怖
沒良心可能不到100萬
所以男朋友要送你鑽石
一定要講
換成黃金
说你喜欢黄金
或是现金
来来来
再来
要黄金是不是
男朋友再给你选一个
对
黄金跟黄金存折是不是
选一个
太难了
哪个好
这个没关系
立马给你看数据
小哥送的什么都好
看数据来来
因为男朋友可能会分手
对
所以买了之后
分手东西不要留下来
看得難過
所以你看這個賣價
我懂你意思了
不要留證據
我留一本
錢留下來 人軸
對不對
存者
我不要留證據
我不要看到那塊黃金在那裡
我怕拿來丟變凶器
對 可是假如要用錢的話
男朋友留下來
趕快把它變賣嘛
買價1.52
賣...
1.520
就是我們去買要1.52
我們拿去賣給台銀1.502
然後呢 條塊呢
你跟他買一台兩
跟台一買一台兩
賣回去56325
來 這兩個誰的價差比較小
太狠了
太難了對不對
好 這個數字太複雜了
立馬教你這個
叫價差比
價差比
價差比呢 尾賣減尾賣除以尾賣
這我懂了 價差比
等於你買賣價中間的差距
對 很聰明
就是你今天買了之後
立馬後悔
不要了 我不要買了 我買回去
我會不會損失
會損失多少
任何東西價差比都會損失
因為任何東西難免都有損失
對 所以我們看
存折的1.520跟1.502
一共差1.2%
就是你現在100萬買
我不想了
拿回來98萬8
這個意思 可以接受
條塊價差比
57875捡568除以57875
2.7%
100万买了
不要了
这条块不好看
拿回去
剩973,000
所以答案就是
存折这样的价差比
我应该可以接受
对
所以全震也是一样吗
一样
我们买全震
我们就会希望说
它好脱手
对
那除了希望它
好脱手以外
你买了
它像死鱼在那边不会动
会不会
小鱼
我不是讲骨鱼
我說像死魚一樣不會動
像死魚也不好聽
對 像死魚不好聽
像木頭一樣不會動
小哥很有抱怨的感覺
沒有 沒有 不要這樣
那要全政會活潑呢
就是要看實質槓桿倍數
對 我們看一下
剛剛你有講啦
五倍以上的話
它的槓桿倍數就還不錯
很活潑
對不對
像這一檔我們剛剛看六倍
對 六倍就不錯
0.56買
漲停板合理加1.04
這樣才會有感覺啊
我才有辦法像你一夜就翻倍
0.56到1.04你就賺0.48
那跌停的話
0.56跌到0.25
也波動蠻大的
可是這跌是跌0.41
這個是賺比較多賠比較少
所以實質杠板倍數高的話
會有這種效應嗎
就是漲比較多 跌比較少
漲的倍數越多
跌的這個趴數
它兩個相比之下會比較懸殊
所以槓桿大的有這種好處
所以槓桿大的
我們就挑槓桿大的就對了
沒錯
好
所以我們現在把
把綜合以上的優點叫低差槓比
差價比跟剛剛講的槓桿比率
叫做差槓比
對 我們就把
要標準喔
差槓比
因為這是我發明的
好 你發明的
我發明的
就是買賣價差比
好 剛剛這個講
這要比較小嘛 對不對
對 買賣價差比
其實它這個買賣價差比很小
對
然後這個實質槓桿倍數很大
哇 這麼好的東西嗎
有 有 有
這麼好
那這種參數呢
我們要小於0.3%
好 參數小於0.3
小哥絕活囉
你知道0.3怎麼來的嗎
怎麼來的
0.3就是我們的證交稅
哦
證交稅是3嘛
對
那這個差槓比0.3%
假如你找到漲全震
差槓比0.3%
代表股票漲0.3%
你的全震就回本
就回本了
而且越低越好
因为如果0.2%
就等于股票漲0.2%
我就回本
所以0.1%
甚至接近于0
还有低于0.1%的
真的
有的
目前市场上还有
好好好
来看一下台积电
差槓比用查的就好
小哥你太了解我们了
讲半天
你要我算价差比
還要算倍數
對 來
X-比呢
因為這個參數太重要了
對
所以我就把它設計在最前面
好
給大家看
X-比這個%數呢
各位看一下
這個最低的才0.04%
那就買嗎
就是你玩它是很容易獲利的
很容易獲利
但是賬權真的有個缺點
就看這邊
它影韌波動力不大穩定
剛剛有講到
好券商的話
不能亂降影韌波動力
好的券商影韌波動力穩定
那是什麼券商我看一下
可以一直降
你這樣子
我看到了
大家自己去猜一猜
來
這麼好的全證
會有什麼好處
各位看一下
這裡有12.33分的時候
股票買價328
全證的買價是2.27
賣價2.28
你可以買到2.28
股票買價328的時候
當股票買價提升到328.5的時候
我們看30秒這個地方
328.5的時候
全震的買價已經到2.3
所以有些人在幹嘛你知道嗎
買盤一跳動他就買2.28賣2.3
就買賣買賣這樣來玩
就盤中這樣來玩就好了
他就看台積電在那邊跳動
他買全震就賺錢
但是那要是找到像小哥講的
完美的權證
就插槓比比較小的
對 插槓比非常小的
你玩太久
因為你這樣子玩
發行商會受傷啊
那我就要買台積電賣台積電
你賺錢他賠錢嘛
他忙
你會讓他很忙
所以他就會修理你
把隱含波多幣降下來
把隱含波多幣就乾脆降下來
隱含波多幣降下來
那個權證價格就便宜了
我懂了
雖然我們找到完美的權證
可是小哥提醒
你一定要去觀察
它的隱含波動率有沒有降
因為券商也沒有辦法讓你一直玩
它如果一降的話
這個權證的條件它就改變了
它的權證價格就瞬間降
對 所以就不是完美的權證了
所以隨時要注意
對 有很多
好 我們這一集其實已經講
很長的時間了
但是我們不會只做一集
所以現在小哥要告訴我們
他預告接下來
買權證有四個最佳時機
我們下一集會來跟大家講
但是現在先乒乓一下
對 法說會除權期強反彈
法說會前出圈西線搶反彈
對 之後會教你怎麼玩
最重要的是最近可以玩這個
第四個 現股不靈軌道開主力買
我今天有看到好幾檔
我等一下來跟你請教
主力買上軌翹
技嘉 技嘉最近也長這樣
對啊 主力買上軌翹
我們播出的時候不曉得技嘉怎麼樣
這小哥只說現象好不好
最近剛翹
對 很緊張
我們有離場啊
對啊 他離開就離場嘛
好 翹到哪裡也不知道
好
不凝通道也很有用
上一集講不凝通道一定要趕快看
因為你現股的走勢會
你全證才會買得對
好 那今天小哥
我們已經講很長了
對 全證小哥不是浪得虛名
我們全證系列會繼續講
因為今天我們只是把最基本的入門概念給你
像趙豪就知道我膽子小
我都會買價內的
可是如果想賭一波
小哥說就可以買價外的
還有趙豪也知道
我現在全證不能一直放
對 因為越放的話時間價值就越差
小哥是建議我們要短進短出
今天交了好多好多的Pepo
但是呢
我們下一集還有更多
就直接告訴你
遇到特殊情況的話
你要怎麼買賣權證
歌有酬必報真的是超補的大補帖
所以我們今天非常謝謝小哥
我們下一集的歌有酬必報
就掰掰囉
掰掰
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜